We have someone who is very sick
A very sick child
She’s malnourished,
Our threshold to send people home is very high
so if someone's an in-patient in normally means they are bad off,
and if they are a little kid in-patient it usually means they are really bad off.
She's known to us
her mother was a patient who died
But last time we saw her about a month and a half ago
she weighed 6 kilos
so she weighed 12 pounds. and although that's not great for a one year old
it's a lot better than 3 kilos which is what she is right now
so this is a concerning downward trend
and we have to be worried that she has TB or something else going on.
I'm trying to maintain a sterile field
but as I was saying to KJ, it's hard to do when there's just flies everywhere.
so but we'd really rather she didn't get an
infection form us doing this to her.
I know love, I know it's uncomfortable and I'm sorry
The left subclavian, it's a central vein so it makes it a little bit easier for us
in this setting
so first I'm going to numb her up and then I'm going to get
all my equipment ready to go
ok baby bear, I'm sorry, I'm sorry
But these veins might still be quite down, and if so we'll have to go into her bone
which I'd really rather not do
but you can't always get what you want.
Alright lady, let's do this huh?
you feel for the part where the collarbone starts to go up in the air
and then you go right underneath it
let's see what we can find
it's gunna be, see if I can get one now
oh for an ultrasound huh
Im passing through it but I can't
stay in it because she is just so clamped down
and we're getting a little bit of a flash but it's just
I can't get in it because it so tiny it's probably
as wide as the needle that I'm using
so it's a little bit of a navigational
you know at the same time I dont want to puncture her lung
you end up riding down the collarbone
alot which is what I'm doing right now.
interosseous isn't that bad,
I mean once she's hydrated then I'm sure
0:03:35.289,0:01:36.450
then we can try this again
osseous means bone. you put it in the tibia so the shin bone.
Lets get you some numbing medicine ok?
just a wee bit.
I know, I know that it hurts and I'm sorry